as the predator makes his way across the  great plains near the beginning of prey  he hunts other lowercase p predators he  kills and skins a rattlesnake he also  spies on a wolf hunting a rabbit after  the wolf lands its quarry the predator  attacks the wolf whose sharp set of  chompers is no match for the highly  skilled and heavily armed hunter the  alien removes the wolf's spine and head  in typical predator fashion in the  previous films we always see predators  polishing human skulls and creating  trophies out of the people they killed  while we don't get to see this predator  do as much with this human prey we do  witness the predator polishing and  cleaning the wolf skull in a clear  reference to the predator tradition of  claiming trophies